Today we are going to discuss some
extremely controversial topics and
because this is going to go on YouTube
there are certain words I cannot say. So
just to warn you I will write down these
words but I will not say them because if
I do say them then I will get censored
on YouTube.
Today we're going to look at how evil
triumphs. Why is the world so evil?
And there's going to be a lot of
extremely disturbing topics we're going
to discuss.
Um, but you're mature and it's important
that we discuss these topics in order to
understand how the world works. So,
let's just start. Um, and we will do a
lot of speculation and theorizing in
this class. So, do not take this as
gospel. Do not believe this is the
truth. The entire point of this class is
to help you develop the theories and the
ideas to better understand the world.
These are tools. Okay? This is not
truth. This these are tools. All right.
So the first question I have for you is
what h what is happening in Israel right
now? As you know, Israel is besieging
bombarding Gaza. You might have seen the
videos on social media. It is
disturbing. It is terrible. What is
happening? The word that is happening,
the word that we use for what what is
happening in Gaza is this word. You are
not allowed to say this word on YouTube,
but that is the intention.
What I will argue though is that the
truth is far more disturbing than this.
What is really happening in Gaza is a
ritual
sacrifice
and this happens quite often in human
history.
If you go back and you look at the real
history of humanity, this happens quite
often. Some of the most um famous
examples are the Aztecs.
We've dug up temples of the Aztecs and
inside the temples are thousands and
thousands of human skulls.
So before they went to war, they
practice human sacrifice. They would
commit mass murder of their enemies in
public. So the Aztecs were really famous
for this. The phoenetians
uh specifically the constant genians uh
we will discuss them later this semester
but the phoenetians were also famous for
a particular type of sacrifice which is
child sacrifice.
The Romans
wrote histories
insulting the Infineticians for
practicing this sort of sacrifice. But
the Romans themselves
practice human sacrifice. What they
would do is that after every major war,
they would capture all the major
leaders, all their enemies, and they
would parade their enemies through the
streets of Rome. This is something
called the triumph. At the end of the
triumph, they would gather enemies at
the temple of Jupiter. Jupiter is their
god. And then they would strangle to
death their enemies.
That's sacrifice. That's human
sacrifice. They didn't call it that,
okay? And they sort of disguised it. But
we know for a fact that they did do
this. So the question for us is
why is it that this happens? Why do the
Aztecs do it? Why do the Phoenicians do
it? Why do the Romans do it? And why is
it today the Israelis do it in
Gaza? And remember, okay,
um what the Israelis are doing is quite
horrific because it is really this sort
of sacrifice. Why? Because 47%
o almost half of the population of Gaza
is under 18 years old.
So the majority of people who are
getting killed are in fact children.
What is most striking or blatant about
what's happening in Gaza is that we can
all see it for ourselves.
And it's almost as though the Israelis
want us to see it and want us to hate
them.
Right? You can see all over the world
popular opinion is turning against
Israel. You have these popular protests
all around the world protesting what is
happening in Palestine.
If they really wanted to do this, right,
there are actually much more effective
ways of doing this. For example, you
could just poison their water or you
could poison the ear so that everyone in
Gaza gets a fast cancer. Right? We have
the technology to do this.
So, so Israel could do it this secretly
and no one would talk about it and in 20
years time, 30 years time, the
population of Gaza would all be gone. It
would be a very secret, right? Instead,
they choose to do this in front of the
world. And my argument to you is that
this is intentional. They want the world
to hate them because by doing this they
create the ultimate taboo.
Right? It we find this disgusting and
contemptuous. So the entire world will
unite against Israel. But guess what?
That's what their religion wants. In the
extreme form of Jewish esquetology or
their religion,
they believe that at the end of the
world, Israel will fight the entire
world and God will help Israel triumph
in the end. So what's really happening
in Gaza is that there are extremists
within the is Israel government who want
to accelerate the process of the end of
the world where Israel will face the
world. And if you think about it, the
entire idea of this ritual sacrifice is
to unite the Israeli population.
And what's extremely disturbing and
horrifying about it is that this works.
Why? Well, let's use an analogy. Okay,
the analogy is this.
In Chinese history,
the most popular military strategy is to
fight with a river behind your back. You
guys have heard of this strategy, right?
where okay um an army is losing okay
it's being scattered by the enemy. So
what the general does is forces the army
to retreat to a river and now with a
river blocking your escape you have a
choice. You can either drown on the in
the river or you can fight to the death
and most soldiers will choose to fight
to the death. And so at this point the
soldiers are unified. They're
galvanized. They're energized. And then
they find a surge of energy to go and
destroy their enemy. Okay, this is the
most popular military strategy in
ancient Chinese history. And guess what?
It's the same as Israel doing this right
now in Gaza. It's the same logic.
Yes, you have a question.
>> So what is the river for the Israel?
Like
>> Yeah, that that that's a good question.
What's a river right here? Right. The
river is a taboo, right? What's the
worst thing you can do in modern
society? Killing children, guys. Right?
So, there's no exit for Israel. You
either go all the way or the world comes
and destroys you anyway.
And in fact, what's really interesting
is that if you go online, you will see
Israelis go around the world and causing
trouble everywhere. They're going to
start fights. They're they shout death
to the Arabs on public buses in the
western world. It's intentional. They
want to unite themselves by dividing the
world, by angling the world. Okay, does
that make sense? All right. So, this is
all very disturbing and I want to slowly
unpack review to reveal to you how this
works. Okay. So, uh, to do this, what
I'm going to do is I'm going to use a
thought experiment.
A thought experiment is this. Let's just
say that there's an island. We don't
know where the island is, but it's an
island and there's no escape from the
island. And on the island there, the
center, it's a hill and it's safe. But
everywhere else you have these flesh
eating monkeys roaming everywhere. Okay.
The problem is that on this island, uh,
the resources you need to survive,
trees, food, and rivers, the monkeys are
there. Okay? There's one safe spot in
the center, but everywhere else if you
want resources, you have to go fight
these monkeys. They're flesheating
monkeys. They want to kill you. They
want to eat you. And there's an infinite
number of them.
Now let's just say that one day for
whatever reason okay we don't know why
but 100
men aging and they range from 15 to 65
years old okay they are mysteriously
transplanted onto this island in a safe
spot
they come from different countries they
do not speak the same language they are
of different ethnicities they are all
poor people in their countries they
don't have much education
So they're there and they realize
quickly that the situation is utterly
hopeless. There's no escape from this
island. These monkeys are everywhere and
they are tough warriors.
And the situation looks bleak. They
don't even speak the same language. They
don't have a common culture.
So at this point you would imagine that
they would feel hopeless and just lie
down and die. But in reality what
happens is the opposite. What happens is
that in this hopeless situation they
find a drive a purpose a spirit to fight
for each other. And what will happen
really quickly? Okay. And this is really
interesting is the first thing that they
will do is
they will develop a common language.
They don't speak the same language. Some
speak Chinese, some speak English, some
speak Spanish, some speak Russian,
doesn't matter. They will very quickly
develop a common language.
And then what they will do is with this
common language they will start to tell
each other stories
of where they come from. And then these
stories will become a common myth, a
founding myth of why they're here.
And they come to believe that God has
chosen them to save the world and that's
why they're here.
Then what they will do is with this new
religion they will start develop rituals
to reinforce this religion. These
rituals include sex.
Okay. So these men will have sex and the
reason why is create intimacy and
bonding
among them and there'll be a lot of
religious rituals as well. Another thing
that they will do
is pick a leader. There's 100 of them.
They need a leader to organize them. And
so we can imagine that during the
leadership election, everyone gets up to
speak. Now the man who's 65, he is wise.
He has experience. He has strategies. So
he delivers a very powerful speech
inspiring everyone and telling people
how they can survive against the flash
eating monkeys. Okay? So he's really
smart.
Then suddenly you have a man up here
who's 15 years old or 16 or 17. Okay? He
is not articulate. He has no ideas. What
what he does is this. He stands in front
of everyone and he's bold and he's brave
and he looks at everyone without saying
a word. He shows them his hand. Okay, he
shows them his hand. Then from his
pocket, he takes out a knife. Okay? And
then he cuts off his hand in front of
everyone.
And he does not cry. He just looks at
everyone
as though nothing happened. Let me ask
you this question. Who does everyone
pick to be their leader? The second
person obviously, right? The man who has
shown sacrifice and commitment and
devotion to everyone else. The old man
has ideas and he will become the advisor
to the leader. But the leader is the man
who is most willing to die for everyone
else. And so in this situation the
bravest among them will come and emerge
as the leader. And as such what will
happen is that these people these men
will become extremely inspired and
devoted. Even though they are weak, they
will learn to become strong.
Even though they are poor and
uneducated, they will learn to be wise
and clever and strategic. They will
radically transform themselves.
And ultimately what will happen is the
idea of cohesion.
Cohesion like brothers, cohesion like a
family. They will understand each other
even though they're from different
cultures. Even though they have
different backgrounds, they will
understand each other better than they
understand their own children and their
own wives. And this cohesion will lead
to something called synchronicity.
Synchronicity.
Synchronicity is when people
act in unison together. Okay. So a very
simple example of synchronicity is a
sports team, right? When you watch a
soccer match, how is that soccer soccer
team able to work together? Well,
because of synchronicity. Because their
minds are alike. It's what we call a
hive mind.
And this allows for something called
telepathy.
They're able literally to think and act
as one. So let me give an example of
this. Let's just say one they're like
these men they're sleeping but one of
them wonders off to collect wood and
then he's attacked by monkeys. It
doesn't matter if he screams because
he's too far away. Would his comrades
know that he's in danger?
They would. Okay. Okay. And the example
here is let's just say you're a mother
and you have children, okay? And one of
them goes off to France on vacation, but
then while he's in France, he gets hit
by a car and he's hospitalized. Would
you as a mother know that he that your
son is in danger? Would you feel it? He
hasn't called you. You don't know about
this, but in your heart, would you know
it? The answer is yes, you would know
it. You would feel something is wrong.
You would get on the phone and try to
call your son. You would, you can't
reach your son. You would call the
police. Okay? You don't know what's
happening, but something in your heart
is telling you, I need to get in touch
with my son.
Okay? And that's how the hive mind
works. That's how synchronosity works.
Let's let's look at another example.
Let's just say that one day you there's
10 of you and you're all collecting wood
and then suddenly you're attacked by
hundred flesh eating monkeys. There's a
bridge that you've created. Okay, it's a
rope bridge. Nine get across the bridge.
All right, but you're the last person.
Okay, and all the monkeys are about to
descend on you
and you know that if the monkeys get
across your comrades are dead. So what
what do you do in this situation?
for the
>> Yeah, you you cut the rope. Okay, you
die. You didn't think about it. You just
kill yourself because what matters is
not your life. What matters is the
family. What matters is the team. And we
know about this because in war, what
often happens is in trench warfare, the
other uh the enemy will throw a grenade
into the trench, right? there's not
enough time to get that to pick up that
uh grenade and for away. So what
soldiers do is they will jump on the
grenade and absorb the explosion thus
killing himself. It happens
instantaneously. No one thinks about it.
You just do it because what matters is
saving your comrades.
And this is what happens.
Okay. A synchronosity develops where
it's almost as though you're able to
reach read each other's minds.
And they keep on doing this for like 10
20 years. And then suddenly, okay, let's
continue a thought experiment. Suddenly
you are transported
back to the real world as though nothing
happened but you have memories
of what happened.
Okay, does that make sense? Okay, you've
experienced 20 years of hell on Monkey
Island. You've dealt the capacity to
work together. You have a hive mind.
You're really energized. You're really
inspired. You're really driven. You have
a new religion
all to yourself.
Now, suddenly you're all trans
transported back to your
real world, your old life. Okay? Now,
what would happen? Well, what would
happen is that the hund of you would
want to come together again, right?
And you would share your experience,
your rituals, your religion with your
children and your grandchildren. And
quickly over time, what will happen is
that
you guys will conquer the world. You
will become the secret elite.
The world is yours. There may be
presidents. There may be famous people.
But secretly, you're the ones who are in
control. Your children, your
grandchildren, your great grandchildren
will inherit this legacy. And they are
the ones who truly control power in the
world. Does that make sense? All right.
Yeah. Question here.
Guy if we like if when the time if this
person really transferred back to the
real reality what if that time already
have a leader that like you are just a
peasant but not a leader
>> okay yeah that's a good question I've
already told you this okay on the
surface there are leaders but the real
power are you guys okay and I'll explain
why all right now um what's also
interesting is that
um while you're on this island, you will
develop certain rituals that are very
strange but are important if you want to
maintain unity. Okay. So, for example,
one strange ritual is the funeral
ritual,
the funeral ritual. Um the idea here is
that when someone sacrifices himself,
you have a huge funeral to sh with that
person. And this may involve you cutting
that person into different pieces and
eating that person. Okay? But you you
you will develop really strange rituals.
Okay? Does it make sense? Okay. So I'm
going to answer your question. Uh why
are these guys in charge and not the
real leaders of society? But first I
want to give you some historical
analogies to this. Okay. How do you know
that what I'm saying is correct? Well,
let's look at certain analogies of h in
history.
All right.
So, Sparta,
Sparta is one of the most famous
military societies in world history.
Sparta is a city-state in ancient
Greece.
And you may have heard of Sparta. Um, a
movie about Sparta was made called 300.
I'm not sure if you guys have seen the
movie 300, but 300 is really about 300
Spartan soldiers who are fighting
millions, not millions, but hundreds of
thousands of Persian soldiers. Persia is
invading mainland Greece. They fight at
a place called Thermopily,
the battle of Thermopily. And this is
the pass into main Greece. The Greeks
have to hold this position. They are to
prevent the invasion. Okay. 300 Spartan
soldiers backed by thousands of other
Greek soldiers make a last stand in this
pass. They are overwhelmed by the
Persian invasion and rather than run
like most people, the 300 soldiers make
a final stand. Their leader is Leonitis
and he tells them, "We will fight to the
death." They all fight to the death and
they're all massacred. And the Persians
take Leonitis's head, cut it off and put
on a on a pike to warn the Greeks, we
are merciless. Eventually, the Greeks
um inspired by the sacrifice of
Leonitis, they will repel the invasion
and destroy the um invaders. So, how do
we get this culture? Okay. Well, the
education system of the Spartans is
really interesting. It's really
disturbing actually. So young boys at
age five and six, they're taken away
from their homes and they are put in a
school run by older boys. Okay? So, so
the older boys are maybe like 10, 11.
And so what happens as you can imagine
is the older boys beat the crap out of
the younger boys. Okay? From day one,
there's no education. They're not
learning anything. All that's happening
is the older boys are just beating the
crap out of the younger boys. But
because this is happening, we call this
like hazing. Okay, this happens actually
a lot um among fraternities and sports
teams there. When they're getting a
crowded out of them, it builds
solidarity. It builds brotherhood. So
these young boys who are five and six,
they learn to love each other because
only by helping each other can they
survive the brutality.
Okay. Then what happens is when they're
11 when they're become 11, 12, 13, when
they hit puberty, this is really
interesting, they become mentored, okay,
mentored by an older soldier, an older
Spartan soldier who's maybe 28, 29, 30,
but he has a family. They become lovers.
They have sex with each other, and this
builds group solidarity. Okay. So during
hazing phase, these young boys learn to
trust each other. They learn how to bond
with each other. Uh during the
mentorship phase, these
young boys learn to think like in a hive
mind. Okay? They learn to be part of a
larger group. Then when they um turn 18,
they um graduate. Okay?
And in order to graduate, what they do
is this. They have a mission. So the
Spartans um have slaves called Helotss.
Okay? These are just people that they've
conquered and who are now work as slaves
in the fields for them. Okay? They're
like serves.
So there are lots of rules governing the
helotss. An important rule is curfew. So
if it's dark at night, you cannot be
outside the house. If you are outside
the house at night, you could be um
executed. Okay? So, as a graduation
mission, these young soldiers hide in
the fields at night, okay? They hide in
the fields and they wait for
the sun to go down. So, it's now dark
and they look for helots to come back
because they're late. And what they'll
do is they'll sneak up behind the helot
and cut their throats. Okay, this is
basically sacrifice.
Okay, human sacrifice. So, the Spartans
did this as well. It's a very common
thing.
And what this does is it builds
group cohesion leading to synchronosity.
Only there are thousand thousands of
city states in Greece. Only Sparta did
this and it made everyone think Sparta
was disgusting. Everyone hated Sparta.
But it kept Sparta unified. It made
Sparta into the dominant military power
in Greece at that time.
Okay.
What happened then is thieves, another
city state in
um Greece, they would copy the Spartan
Spartan system. Okay. But they made it
voluntary. So if from if it so in Sparta
you have to be an elite to be part of
the system.
But in thieves anyone could join the
system. Okay? And they call the system
the sacred band.
um of 300 soldiers and they were again
lovers. Okay, but this is really
important for you guys to understand. At
this time in history, there's no concept
of homosexuality. It was perfectly
permissible. No one cared if you had sex
with
men or animals or whatever. Okay, it was
not a big deal. This comes much later in
modern times. Back then, this was not
considered homosexuality was not
considered a concept. Okay? If you're
out in the field, if you're out at war
for like years and years and there's no
woman around, you're going to have sex
with other men. It's a very natural
thing to do. Okay? It doesn't mean
you're homosexual. Okay? So, the Sacred
Band of Thieves became the dominant
military power after Sparta. Okay? It's
called the Sacred Band. And they were
like the um vanguard. They were the
spearhead. They would be the first in
battle and they were so ferocious that
their enemies would run away. Okay. Then
what happened is that Macedonia
would
copy the Theian system.
Um who is the most famous Macedonian in
the world? Do you guys know which
Macedonian is the most famous ever in
human history? You know the name but you
may not know he's Macedonian
the Great. Okay. His father is Philip
II.
Philip II is the one who actually built
the greatest army in the world, the
Macedonian army. And it was actually the
great, his son, who would take this army
and conquer Persia. Okay, we'll learn
this later on. But Phil the second
learned learned all this from thieves.
And at first, Macedonian thieves were
allies, but Phil the second was very
ambitious. So then he start to want he
wanted to conquer all of mainland
Greece. And in 338
uh BCE at the battle of uh Traonia,
Macedonia fought against the combined of
thieves and Athens. And Macedonia
destroyed thieves in Athens. Okay?
Because Macedonia basically copied the
system from Sparta and thieves. At this
point, Macedonia should have destroyed
the entire Theban and Athenian army. But
when all was lost, the sacred band,
they stood in the middle of the field
and they blocked the advance of
Macedonian charge
so that everyone could escape back into
the cities. They did not fear death.
They welcomed death. Okay? For them,
what mattered was honor and sacrifice.
And that's how you create the greatest
army in the world. Okay, does that make
sense? So these historical analogies
give credence to our thought experiment.
Okay, now we're going to look at a
question which is okay,
why does a system work?
Okay, so let's do game theory.
Game theory.
Game theory is just a study of how you
how to win games. Okay, it's a very
general thing. So, let's do a thought
experiment and just say there's about a
million people in the world. Okay,
there's a million people in the world
and they're all trying to win the game
against each other, but only only one
can win. Well, according to game theory,
the best way to win a game is by Does
anyone know?
Cheating. Okay, cheating. If you follow
the rules, you will never win the game.
You have to cheat. And in this game, the
best way to win is by coordinating with
other people, right? Because everyone's
playing by himself. So, if you can work
with other people, then that gives you a
huge advantage over everyone else,
right?
The problem with this is the moment that
people start coordinating it forces an
arms race of coordination. So maybe
these two are working together these
four now are forced to work together
which now forces these five to work
together. Okay.
So if you are the first to work together
you're get you get screwed in the
process. So if you cheat you have to
cheat.
Okay. You have to coordinate without
people knowing you're actually
coordinating together. You have to
conspire secretly.
Okay. And there are different ways to
collaborate secretly. Okay. So let's
let's look at examples. So family is one
example, right? Of coordination,
synchronosity. Another example is
religion.
Um if you have a leader,
right? if you um have a similar race,
ethnicity,
and you have a sim similar language.
Okay, so these are examples of how you
you get people to coordinate together.
The problem is that these are all
obvious to people, which forces them to
do the same thing. Okay. But there's a
strategy that you can use that allows
you to coordinate secretly and defeat
all your enemies. And this strategy is
called transgression.
Transgression. The breaking of taboos.
The breaking of social norms. The
breaking of social laws. Transgression.
Okay. So let's study this concept.
All right. So the idea is that
um the theory is that
the greater you transgress. Okay. This
is a level of transgression,
the greater your cohesion
which leads to synchronosity. Okay,
that's a theory I want to propose to
you.
All right. So, transgression, I mean,
it's it's a very simple idea. You're
breaking the rules, right? You're
cheating and therefore everyone wants to
put you in prison,
which means that the only way that you
can survive is if you keep the secret
among your group, right? Which forces
cohesion. Does that make sense? All
right. And we see this in all aspects of
society, right? So the most basic form
of transgression is just joking
or pranking, right? So for example, you
guys, six of you decide, you know what?
We're going to play a joke on the
school. We're going to cover all the
rooms in with toilet paper. It's a joke.
It's a prank. But obviously, you don't
want to get caught because the school
will punish you.
And this joke and this prank will make
you more cohesive, right? Because now
you have a secret among amongst yourself
and anyone betrays you, you're all
screwed, right? Does that make sense?
That's a logic.
Um, the other thing that's really
interesting is that when you transgress,
when you break a taboo, you feel
empowered,
you feel liberated,
and it becomes addictive.
Right? You fill the school with toilet
paper. You're like, "That was a lot of
fun." Well, was it fun? Because you
broke the rules. You feel I'm more
powerful than my teacher. Then, so you
keep on doing more and more of this
stuff, right? Then you may be like,
"Hey, let's go to the store and steal a
candy. That candy may cost $1, nothing,
right? But you try it and you are
terrified. You're seized by doubt.
You're ceased by fear.
Sorry. So, um this is the um sound that
tells us that we should go on break. But
but again, we don't go on break in this
class. Okay. So, I apologize. We're not
we're not taking a break. We keep on
going. Okay. But that's what the sound
is. Okay. So, um,
you're terrified because your mother,
your teachers, everyone told you
stealing is bad, right? But when you
actually go and do it, how do you feel?
You feel energized. You feel liberated.
You feel empowered. And if your friends
are with you, how the friendship becomes
much more unified, much more cohesive,
much more synchronized. Does that make
sense? And now you want to learn, let's
break more rules. Let's see what happens
if we break more and more rules and you
keep on going because it's addictive and
ultimately there's a transgression that
is the ultimate taboo which is what you
guys know. Yeah. Right. This
right?
Can you think of a more worse
transgression than this?
That's why they do it because it feels
empowering. It releases energy. They do
it because they believe that when you do
this, it releases divine energy.
And when you when you actually do it,
okay, I'm guys, I'm not telling you to
go do this, okay? Please do not do this,
okay? And please remember, okay, this is
evil. We should not be doing this. But
when you actually go and do it, those
who can do it, they feel as though they
are now
inudated that now they are now filled
with divine energy. They found the
secret of the universe. They found the
ultimate power in the world. Another
transgression which is not as bad but
pretty bad is the idea of
incest. Right? And there are secret
societies out there, guys, that do this.
And you know what, guys? I I hate to
tell you this, okay? But they do it in
public in front of everyone else because
that creates both group unity,
synchronosity, and it releases in their
minds divine energy.
They have now access to God.
If you want to know what secret
societies do, well, um, yeah,
this and this. Okay.
And again, there's only a small group of
people, but now we know why these people
control the world because they're able
to keep secrets, because they're more
motivated than everyone else, and
they're able to work together
in a way that allows them to achieve
ultimate power.
Th these leaders you see right these
leaders you see they are puppets they
are just the face the real power are
these secret societies that practice
these rituals and again I'm not saying
this is a truth I'm just saying this is
a possible theory about how the world
works right because this is a class of
speculation it's a class of theory don't
think this is the truth okay but you can
think about how this works and ask
yourself.
Does it explain the world?
Okay. All right. So, having explained
this, what I want to do now is go into
the deep theory as to why this is
happening. Okay. So, if you talk to
these people and they're honest with
you, they they'll tell you that when we
do this, we access God and God gives us
divine power because they're
superstitious and they're stupid. Okay?
Just because they're the lead, just
because they're powerful people, does
not mean they're clever. In fact,
they're kind of stupid if you actually
meet them, right? But um I'm going to
explain how this system works. And when
I do when I explain to you, it will make
sense.
Okay? But are we are we clear so far
about what's happening, guys? All right.
I know this is disturbing and I know
uh I'll probably get banned on YouTube
for this, but it's important that that
that we do this. Okay. All right. So now
I explain the theory as to why this is
happening. How is a transgression is
able to unleash divine energy. Okay. So
um Kant we will look at some major
thinkers and um they're really deep
thinkers and we'll go deep we'll go more
into them this semester but I'm going to
introduce them. Okay. So Kant remember
from the first class Kant had a theory
of how the world works. There is no
objective reality that we see. Okay. So
before the assumption was that we just
absorb reality. Okay. But Kant says that
we are active. Sorry we we'll wait for
this.
[Music]
So
Khan says that we were active
participants in reality. How? Well
because our brains are filters. We add
space and time to reality. Space and
time does not exist outside of us. Okay?
So the objective reality is called
nomina.
Okay? The things in themselves do not
worry about these names. But this is the
objective reality. What happens is that
for our filters, we interact with the
nomina and that creates something called
the phenomena.
The things that we see the phenomena.
Okay? And that's the world we know. The
nomen we can never ever know. That's the
theory of Kant. Okay. And this has been
confirmed by neuroscience.
So this is basically the most accurate
model of the world that we have. The
problem though is that Kant's conception
of the world creates three questions.
Okay. The first question that first
question is what is the nomina?
Kai says we can never know it but we
still want to know it. Okay, that's the
first question. Second question then is
who gave us these filters,
right? Where do our filters come from?
How do our minds work and who created
our minds in the first place? The second
question. The third question is if we
are all seeing the world for our own
lens, how do we know that we're seeing
the same world? How do our perception of
the world align together?
Okay,
so Kant creates these problems. Hegel
who comes after Kant Frederick Hegel by
the way he proposes a solution to this
to these three problems and what he says
is this and this is really important for
us to understand is the nomen is the
gist.
The gist is hard to translate. We
usually translate to mean spirit.
Okay. So what Heggo is saying is that
the spirit world is what creates the
material world.
We are just a shell. What really matters
is the spirit world. Now it's really
important to understand the concept of
the gist. Okay? And again there's it's
German but there's no actual English
translation for it. So it's best to see
guys as a combination of three words
that derive from guys. Okay. These three
words are
ghost,
geyser and gist. Okay,
so these three English words are
derivatives of the German word gist,
right? Most words in English are
actually German origin. Sorry, not not
most words but many words. Okay. All
right. Ghost is just a parallel reality
that exists alongside us, right? A
spiritual world. That's the first
concept. Geyser is just a force that is
exploding or becoming or expanding.
So this guys is constantly expanding and
becoming
gist. G just means the essence of things
the core of things. Okay. So the real
truth in the world is the gist. Not what
we see but what is invisible to us.
Okay. So that's the idea of the gist.
Does that make sense? Now with the guys,
we can answer all three questions. The
nomena, the real world is the spiritual
world, not the material world.
It's the gist
that gives us these filters.
And because we're all seeing the world
through the gist,
we see the same world. Okay.
So now this creates another problem
which is where did the gist come from?
What is the gist?
Okay. And here we will look at
Plato and Dante.
Okay. So um
um again this is a really deep theory
and we'll go more deeply into this as
the semester um moves but I just first
want to introduce the idea to you right
now. Okay so this comes from Plato and a
religion called Nostism.
Okay the Gnostics Gnostic just means
knowledge. Okay. Um so in the beginning
the big bang the force is the monad
or the uh the one. Okay there are
different names for this thing or news.
Just think of this as a supreme god.
Okay the big bang the the the force of
like like the the the sun almost. Okay
the spiritual son of the universe. The
news works by breathing. When he
breathes, he vibrates his divine power
and through this he creates new beings
called diads. Diads are just peers of
um forces. Okay, these diads then create
different realities. All right, so
different realities are being created
through this inaction and eventually you
reach earth.
Okay. So in other words, what Plato and
Nostics are telling us is that the gist
is a multi-layer,
multi-dimensional
world that we access all the time.
Okay?
Does it make sense? And the earth what
we see it is just the out the most outer
shell in this
universe.
Is this clear to you guys? All right. So
now the question then is what is the
purpose of life in the world? And what
Plato says is that the purpose of life
in this world is to return to the monad.
Okay? And guess what guys?
This is actually the um framework for a
lot of religions including Hinduism,
right? And Buddhism. This this is what
the Hindus and the Buddhists believe as
well. Nirvana is the return to the
monad. I'm not sure if you guys have
studied religion before, okay? But
that's the idea. So what Plato says is
that through the pursuit of knowledge,
philosophy, the love of knowledge, you
can return to the
monad. Okay.
Um Dante and we will study Dante in
depth later on. Okay. But Dante has
another solution. What Don Dante says is
that the manad the monad is love.
Okay. And the monad because he creates
things, his divine spark emanates
throughout the universe. Okay. So there
is a divine spark in us. And this divine
spark is called love.
So we are able to love
people. Mothers love children. Um you
love each other because of this divine
spark in you. And the more you love, the
more you return to the Mona.
Okay. So Plato says pursue knowledge.
Donna says pursue love.
Okay.
So now the question is, okay, this
sounds all very good,
but why does evil happen in the world?
Okay, what's the source of evil?
Right. That's interesting. Okay. You
have you have this theory of the
universe. But then the question then is
why do people do bad things then? Why is
there sacrifice in the world? Why why
are people doing all these bad things
and not only getting away getting away
with it, but they're also controlling
the world? That's a big question, right?
So um for Plato the answer is very
simple. This world doesn't matter. Who
cares if they control this world? It's a
fake shadow world.
Ignore them. Just focus on the pursuit
of knowledge because that allows you to
be one with the monad. Okay? Who cares
about this world? Give them what they
want. Give them their power, their fame,
their money. Who cares?
Dante's answer is actually very
interesting. Okay, that's that's Plato's
answer. It doesn't matter. This world
doesn't matter. Who cares what happens
in this world? It's a prison anyway.
Donnie actually proposed something
different. He says this,
if the monad is love,
love is trust.
So the monad loves us and as a result
the monad gives us free will. Now free
will can lead to bad things for example
this world but he has no choice in the
matter because for him to interfere
means to take away our free will and
that's and free will is his greatest
gift to us. Okay.
But now and then what he will do is he
will send messengers to our world to
remind us that there is a divine spark
in us and we can activate it and achieve
a greater consciousness. And these
messengers are
Plato, Dante, right? Jesus,
right? Doesn't make sense. So now and
then the Monet will send
um fool the gist. Okay. The Monach will
implant ideas in these people who will
then
tell us the truth. But it's our choice
whether or not to believe it because the
Mona has given us free will. All right?
So for Plato, what's important is the
pursuit of knowledge. For Dante, what
matters is the pursuit of love to love
each other unconditionally.
Okay? Um and that's what they tell us.
What the system also tells us is that
the powerful
want to deny this system, right? Because
if they control earth, the fake world,
they want to make it as real as
possible.
Does that make sense? That's the source
of their power. The belief that the only
that matters is the material world, the
prison that we live in.
And that's why we have
science, right? Science is negation of
the spiritual world and the validation
of the material world. If you cannot see
it, it must be fake.
Right?
Okay. So that's how power works.
Now transgression
works in this model because
transgression allows the powerful to
align to a certain part of this
universe. Okay? Because in this universe
there are evil forces as well. Does that
make sense? So for example, the metaphor
is think of the internet, right? Well,
there are millions and millions of
websites and through transgression by
doing the same evil act, what the power
have done is they've locked on to the
same website,
right? And because they locked on the
same website, it allows for
synchronosity. It allows for them to
commit uh to think alike and to behave
the same way.
Okay.
All right. So, that's the general
theory. And again, this is all
speculation. I'm not telling you this is
true, but I'm giving you a framework to
work with to better understand why
things happen. We're just speculating.
We're using our imagination here, right?
Um, I know this is a lot, but Kant,
Plato, Hego, Dante, we will go much more
deeper into over the semester. So I just
introduced these ideas now. Okay.
Questions guys.
Okay. Uh you you had a question from
last class, right?
>> Right. So So can you ask a question from
last class and I'll answer it first.
>> All right. From last class, you
mentioned that um the ones that control
society are those old pensioners, right?
because they get revenues from the
youngers and they control the society.
Um in our society I do see signs or
phenomena that um the government are
sort of helping the old patients by
creating more um say entertainment or
facilities that benefit them. So why is
that? Is that possible that the the
government also benefit benefits from
old pensioners actions or is actually
the governments are controlled by old
pensioners?
>> Yeah. I mean u we we discussed this last
class but it's the pensioners the old
people who control society control the
culture who control government right
because in China from a first day you're
taught to respect your elders right
you're taught that elder pe elderly
people are worth um emulating they're
worth they're worth studying from
they're they're what's most precious
about our society so it makes sense that
the government would create policies to
most benefit the elderly okay that's
that's is the structure of Chinese
society. Respect for the elderly. Okay,
thank you. Any more questions, guys?
Yep. Ember has a question.
>> Um, so I was just thinking about the
model and I think
>> uh yeah, this model that we have on the
board.
>> Um, so like you said, the existence of
evil is
>> if you don't mind repeating yourself.
>> Oh yeah. So what is evil?
>> Yeah. Okay. In in the system.
>> Okay. So, um in the system what is evil
is the denial of the system. Okay. Okay.
>> So, because the monad is the truth, it's
love. Right. So, the closer you move to
the monad, that's what's good. The
further you move away from the monad,
that's what's evil. Right? So, at the
very end of this model is earth. So the
more you embrace the material world, the
more you uh deny the spiritual world,
that's what's evil in this in in this
model.
>> Okay.
>> So for Plato, the what's good is the
pursuit of knowledge and what's evil is
the pursuit uh the denial of of
knowledge, which includes by the way
art,
right? Movies because movies are just a
shadow of the shadow world. We if the
world we live live in is fake and movies
all they do is depict this fake world
then it makes things worse.
>> Okay. And Dante uh whatever
um allows for more love is good. What
allows for less love is bad.
>> Okay.
>> Um so just to add on to that. So what if
um like we mentioned earlier sacrifice
sacrifice can be considered as a way to
unite people. It creates cohesion. Yeah.
>> And with cohesion
>> it unlocks divine energy because you're
accessing a part of this model.
>> Okay.
>> Yeah. Does that make sense?
>> Yeah.
>> Right. And and that's why
>> as they're doing this sacrifice they are
worshiping a certain god.
>> Right. So sacrifice is part of their
religion. It's not done independently.
They have a religious framework for the
sacrifice and that's why they do it.
Right? They don't do sacrifice for a
personal sacrifice. They do sacrifice um
as a consummation of their religion
because that's what their religion
demands of them.
>> Mhm.
>> Right. And because so the worship of
God, they're sacrificing these people to
send to this god.
>> Okay.
>> Right. So they're accessing a part of
this model which is a lower
part. Okay. M
>> and there are there are evil beings in
this model as well, right? But but they
go lower.
>> So by okay I'm trying to So by being
evil we're like doing the bad deeds we
get as long as it creates love in
Dante's theory it gets us ultimately
closer to the
>> to the monad. Yes.
>> But the evil now that we perceive is
constructed by our current society. So
>> yeah, so what D is saying about core
society is that our society is first and
foremost anti- love. It does not allow
for people to love each other. So for
example, school, right?
>> So um without school, your parents would
just care about your happiness.
>> But because of school, parents care
about your grades and whether or not you
get into a elite American college
>> and whether or not you get a good job.
And so the parents deny your free will.
They deny your agency and as a result
you don't feel loved.
Okay. So that's what Donna would argue.
Our society is anti- love because the
society is constructed in a way that
does not allow for normal human
relationships to flourish.
>> Right? In a normal relationship, your
parents would just let you do whatever
you want. I would think, you know,
>> but because they're like, "No, no, no.
If I let you do whatever you want, you
will not do well in school and you won't
be able to get a job and then you'll
become, I don't know, unemployed and a
drug addict. Who knows?" Okay. Right.
That's how they think.
>> Mhm.
>> Does that make sense?
>> Yeah. So the denial of free will is
anti- love and therefore it's evil and
make it limit Yeah. It limits you from
getting closer to Monad.
>> That's right.
>> Okay, great.
>> Exactly. Thank you.
>> Yeah.
>> Just like the uh what Amber mentions
that this world is anti- love, but what
is the purpose of like not letting us
get closer to the Monet?
That's a good question, right? Why are
they doing this? Because the people in
power want to stay in power, right?
Because what they're doing it goes
against the monad,
but they want to stay in power. So they
gain like benefits such as power by
disobeying the monad and letting others
like disobeying the monad because they
can keep their power.
>> Okay. So, so let so let let us be very
clear. Okay, this is really important.
Different people will interpret this
model in a different way. Okay, in their
conception, the monad is the evil one.
Their god is the good one. They're
liberating us from the monad by making
us more focused on the material world.
Okay, does that make sense? But the
reality is that they were able to get
their power because they were they had a
religion that promoted transgression
which allowed them to coordinate well
together. And now that they have this
power, they need to rationalize why they
have this power and they need to develop
systems to maintain this power. That's
why we have the world we live in today.
Does that make sense?
Okay. Does that make sense? They're
powerful. They want to maintain a power.
So they will think of new ideas that
allow them to keep this power even if it
means denying the truth. Okay?
And and again guys this is a theory. No
one knows if this is true or not. I
don't know. Okay.
But like what you just mentioned that
nomad has two meanings to either
>> No. The nomad does not have two
meanings. It has one. It has different
names but one meaning. Okay, this is
really important for you to understand.
>> There are different names for this but
it is the sun. Okay, the divine son, the
source of all life.
>> So Plato defines nomad as knowledge and
dentine defines nomad as love.
>> No, no, no, no. Okay,
listen. Okay, you have to get this
straight. Okay, this is everything.
Okay, love, knowledge, everything. Okay.
The question that Plato and Dante are
debating is how do you return to the
monad? Okay. So for Plato it's the
pursuit of knowledge that allows you to
get closer to the monad. For Dante it's
a p pursuit of love. Okay. But this is
the one and all the infinite and
eternal. What play would say is that
this is the perfect.
This is the immutable. It will never
change and it's the eternal. It's always
been there and it will always be there.
>> Okay. It's really similar to Buddhism.
>> It is exactly Buddhism.
>> You're like looking at the same thing.
It's like more spiritual. Yes.
>> Aspect of the world and like the
ultimate end of things. It's more like
abstract concept. It's not something
physical that we can um interpret as one
thing or another.
>> Yes. This is exactly Buddhism and
Hinduism. Okay. So this is really
interesting how different religious
traditions working in different
localities have the same conception
of the world of the universe and c can
we can we give someone else an
opportunity to to speak please okay can
can someone else ask ask question
like like like I know I know you're
enthusiastic but sometimes you want to
step back and absorb the idea okay so so
you've asked a lot of questions but Go
home, think about this some more. Okay,
does that does that make sense? Okay,
does anyone want else want to ask
questions?
Okay, one more question. Okay,
>> so like just to confirm that
>> uh Plato and Dante just like gives us
the way to approach nomad, right?
>> Okay. Um can you ask the question again?
I I I I don't
>> like I want to confirm that Plato or
Dantain they because they uh Plato said
that to learn knowledge and Dante said
to pursue love so they gives the way to
to let us approach Monad right so the
monad in the conception of everything is
the same okay it is a source of
everything
Plato and Dante are proposing different
ways to achie to be come closer to the
monad
Right? For Plato, it's like spend your
entire life learning mathematics,
specifically geometry, because he thinks
that geometry is really the language of
of the universe, the secret language of
the universe. Dante says that's too
hard, guys. That's not intuitive.
Like for Plato's an elitist, right?
Plato is like only if you come to my
school and you learn geometry, sacred
geometry, will you access heaven. D is
like that makes no sense. The Monad
would not create a system which only the
elite, the chosen could access him. The
Monad if he truly loves everyone will
give everyone the capacity
to reach him. And that capacity that
that is accessible to everyone is love.
Right? Doesn't matter who you are, you
can all love. But quite honestly, there
are there are not that many people in
the world who can do calculus. Right.
Right. So Plato's like, "You have to do
calculus." Plato is like, and D is like,
"That's just ridiculous. That's the most
ridiculous thing in the world."
Okay. Does that make sense now?
Okay. Um, any more questions, guys?
>> I actually
like why is that like a lot of other
like religions and you know, Plato or
like Dante, they came to the same
realization of Monard? Like why is that?
like it's from different places in the
world, different regions, but like why
do they all have kind of the same thing
about wisdom or like knowledge in
general?
>> Yeah. So, so um that's a really good
question and the answer is the gist,
right? The answer is where do our
thoughts come from and where do our
thoughts go? Do you really think that
it's our brain that produces thoughts?
Why is it that we're the same brain,
right? same neur neurological structure
but we have different ideas and why is
it that I have so many ideas and you and
others have limited ideas
well
like biologically we cannot explain it
okay we never explain it so if you study
neuroscience one thing that will never
ever ask is where do our thoughts come
from which is weird because that should
be the most basic question right that's
the first question you ask but they
never ask that why because they cannot
answer it and the answer the possibility
is The gist exists and our ideas come
from the gist. And when we think of
ideas, it goes back into the gist,
right? It's a ghost. It is with us and
is not with us.
>> There's just like a big system out there
that everything comes from there. So all
of things will go back there eventually.
>> Exactly. Exactly. And and that's and and
that's why and that's how we can explain
why all these different religions have
the same conception of the universe
because they're getting this conception
through inspiration, right? Through
communication with the guys,
right? Does that make sense?
Okay.
I I think that makes a lot more sense
than oh the synapses in our brains, you
know, they fire together and they hit
and like oh we have an idea. I don't
know. Okay.
Okay. All right. So great. Uh we will
continue this next class. Okay.